[ __ ] you could've been with his face
all day he was gone all [ __ ]
day you missing sell and I'll add you
for me cuz you want to be a dummy cuz
you want to fall so [ __ ] you feel me
and I can't follow no [ __ ] cuz a [ __ ]
can't do me nothin I'm talking you can
[ __ ] make me do it busting butt and a
vision even dude I have for time you
feel me okay I'm from Las Vegas Nevada
and I walk from Las Vegas Nevada thought
I was boring and I'm unfortunately I
moved to LA like well I didn't move out
here basically I'm just out here like on
my own being you feel me like I'm not
here because I want to be out here you
feel me like yes I did lie to you I'm
not 18 I'm 17 you know like and yes I
did I reversed childhood like 50 when I
was 15 I lost my mom to may 2nd 2017 I
don't have ice my mom because she had
stage four coaches shared blood clots in
her lungs
I like I don't know like when I was 13
when I was like 12 like 10 to 13 I got
turned out to the game I was a
prostitute and he was just like ever
since then like I was in Oakland I had
been to Oakland San Diego [ __ ]
like I don't mean everywhere open like
Richmond like that versus got up
everywhere he took me everywhere in the
bay like you've not even been the island
hold on blades like that is nothing you
know but I feel like
I should have did something different
you know already yeah
no wait let me take him because when it
was like when I was like 13 14 like it
was fine
you feel me like like what like it was
super funny you don't even know that but
I wanted to know why I was attracted to
that type of stuff you know I wanted to
know why because I got big chains and go
rings like and swag like was always
attracting me you feel me
not attracted to me attracted me you
know what I mean I'm going on to like
like
drugs make people do anything you know
personally pull up like the [ __ ] that
be all adjectives holding and stuff like
that suck dick [ __ ] for $20 like $20
like that while be looking like $20 come
on out says you don't wanna figure
something just go make some more money
for me
I mean $40 $50 on me at least it's like
it's better you for me then what the
[ __ ] they usually do you then you get it
high with them and listen to me when
they pull up y'all getting and y'all go
buy some crack [ __ ] he spent $40 on
some crack and get you 20 come on now on
me like say that like just give me the
whole 60 you know but they don't think
like that because they're doing it for
the harder chasing that hard you know
like I'm gonna chase my dream before me
and I'm gonna change my future you mean
it's just like if I feel like a
situation I feel like a [ __ ] is gonna
bring me down or like get to me like
inside where it's gonna scar my life I'm
gonna get home you know what I mean like
I'm not gonna sit around and just know
you know because I know what type of
female I am you know I'm not nobody
[ __ ] I'm not nobody
ho I'm not nobody none of that you feel
me I'm somebody quitting if I can't be
there like what is I'm here for you feel
me like oh no it was just like oh no
people are by ask my god like did my
eggs like he like he like I was just
like forced me to hit the puppy and slam
crystal I don't want that [ __ ] you feel
me like and you know you I swear to God
on my life he'll get mad if I don't
wanna [ __ ] you feel like be some of my
teary-eyed only [ __ ] you you think I
don't suck no dick you think I like we
did I say it every day like four time
like I'm cool you know I mean like I got
any without look before me but he's just
like like like I don't know I he's like
like
[ __ ] Guinea Euphemia's like he used
to beat me up they forced me like you
feel me like that's not who you don't
know me because just how you not giving
a [ __ ] I can give a [ __ ] adjust oh call
the police they put you in jail
you feel me cuz you not know what type
of female dealing with you know but I'm
not like that you cuz a [ __ ] could get
life out here playing with me you for me
because I'm using me I'm only 17 yes I
can put y'all I won't we I won't call
the police but yes I can't call the
police but we'll just make enough force
me even me have sex with a movie with
the world you know what I mean like and
it's just like they like then what's
gonna happen you know
but then nobody think like that you know
what I mean the Davis fire just they
knew each other for oh this long and
this law like it's okay you know
like like it's not you know like it's
not I swear to God [ __ ] they turn gay
out here off for drugs like some of the
finest [ __ ] to like boy you getting
like oh that's crazy
you feel me I swear to god you see more
like it's just crazy
you know like it's just like unreal you
know is so unreal
I mean you don't get it messed up and my
birthday
we're not turn 18 I'm like I'm like I
ain't gonna lie to y'all but just I'm
not to start like stripping you know and
I think that's something that I wanna do
and I'm not gonna lie to you I want to
be the type of lawyer that just that
saves the guilty people you know cuz
everybody not guilty you know what I
mean like it's the reason why I killed
that [ __ ] you feel me it's the reason
why he raped that [ __ ] you know what I
mean
it's a reason why something you don't on
me like it's a reason why you know what
I mean agents like that's just me oh no
like oh I'd like to have fun you know I
think that would be fun like I know it's
a lot of stuff that I could do blood
think I like stripping Google kind of
like you know go of me because when I
was younger I was a praise dancers like
a church
you're not like I do think dancing like
a little bit you know is over so there's
stripper stripping
[Music]
I mean yeah but that's that's just a
higher class of prostitution you know
like the stage you know I mean oh how
you got like strippers explore so I'm
like on Backpage and stuff like that
like snapchat like yes does you know
besides having just beast um down
tiptoes down to the ground you know just
walking up the Figaro and like you know
why shouldn't she like that
that should get hot and it's just like
it's a beautiful we're going to jail
y'all go to jail you don't know me like
so I just like that's like smarter you
know and I'd probably just be like a
bartender sometimes no but I don't get
it next up I have like I got a lot of
goes you know what I mean like a just
like like oh no I just like this is fun
to me like oh no I feel like king of one
differently but I mean I don't know like
I just like this is recite I just like
this is getting me ready for the real
life when it comes my way you know what
I mean because I like I have not been
living like like to y'all like I when I
say on my age I just live here you're a
baby like you feel me cuz you're like my
age ain't nothing compared to yours you
know so it was just like my godly life
it was baby like like you ain't you
ain't you feel like they'd be like you
anything nothing I did like how much
time they don't know that you know I
mean like this the situation that I mean
I could be ready any time for just like
I'm ready like I mean like I'm not gonna
say like I want me to die but the life
that I'm in and what I'm doing and how
I'm doing it I mean ain't no telling
what's gonna happen you know I mean like
being out here tomorrow you promised
being out here day I mean [ __ ] you you
your emotions on being jail if your
nothing's gonna wake up the next morning
cuz cuz I mean come on are you
you know what like you know but like I
know I'm gonna lie to you I got
something I do like gonna be thinking
like man like you know like you know I
don't know like [ __ ] is scary out here
you know he's scary for me in all
situations for nobody you know but this
is just temporary you thinking I don't
like oh never like let nothing get to me
you know I've always I don't know
nothing it to me I'm always gonna let me
close before the door all right so like
I don't like like out here like as you
see like how you had my foot have a
texture on down that's because I think
like guess they've been out here for a
minute but that ain't [ __ ] you owe me
like you guys do too grown of a cat to
be scratching the ass buy some drugs you
know what I mean like bye-bye
that's like like this how putting the
people I saw here is all of it right so
so so I all be trying to take advantage
a time right but like sometimes it just
be like I've got to you know and
I just been looking at situations like
like like like YouTube like like saying
like you - oh of a dog to be stretched
like to be like to be and to like to be
scratching and I mean not even scratch
like to be been the edge buy a puppy you
feel me and it's like you're too old to
be trying to deal with a situation or
not even situation like not like like
you're too old of a person to still have
kids you know like you know I mean like
to still have a kid like my frame you
know like people out here they know I
like like like they dig like they like
you feeling like this is damn you know
what I mean like people die down here
i peep like everything you know I mean
like today's a funeral going on a
[ __ ] series you know it's just
like like oh get it sometimes you know
what I mean because it's just like you
could do anything you know like your
wife didn't stop just because she was in
a tent you know I mean like the first
day you got it I came down here no
matter what age was you should've died
do something about it you feel like you
can went back to school you like the leg
is out of here that's like in our 20s we
could imagine school you know me like
you could've did something with yourself
but no you let the drugs take over you
you know and like to be honest I don't
expect nobody out here you know like
like yes I like they call me baby D out
here you know like I'm the baby you know
so it's just like like like oh no they
may be trying to like like you know baby
D off a Friday
oh that's I could move now I'm kind of
like I'm not kind of like her but oh no
like oh I'm kind of like me you know
I'm not downtown just to be downtown you
know I'm moving I'm doing everything for
a [ __ ] reason you know and just like
I've got goals in life you know and if
they don't go hard plan
let me apologize to me and my [ __ ]
mistakes that I made I he's grown up as
a child you know coz I mean could I
could be going to school and be like
being a nurse or something you know but
I want to run chase like again but I'm
I'm trying to like give mom I'm trying
to like get a fake ID you know blend I
like that smells like path like a blue
bye sister I'm trying to work at the
real that was always why I came back
from Vegas though so I could like would
go to the strip club I so I can get in
fact that we shop on a tongue stud I
wouldn't work I would be a stripper oh
yeah yeah I feel like everybody else
down here and in my life even my family
they be trying to like talk down you
know like oh yeah like you only 17
you've got to be at home for school but
with the world like [ __ ] like what
you're doing is at 17 like like would
you film me like I know you wouldn't ask
oh you see me because [ __ ] you I know
you don't mind I'll refer oh that's
right for 22 years
are you gonna be like damn I dropped out
look I mean um yeah go I went 11th grade
I didn't go to 9th obtained I went to
11th oh dude and I went where I know so
basically I mean I shot yeah I dropped
out [ __ ] and that's what the young
yeah I'm gonna lie like but downtown
like dancing shut down never catch me on
Sunday because they $24 like that I need
a week like to like Orange County
Register and step over to like if he had
the money everywhere Brian gonna lie to
me I'm trying to go to Miami though like
we're trying to get some money when like
it's like la burn don't count like it's
burnt out now I yeah he's like that
Oh me it is you feel me like I just say
don't watch like to me like like in the
projects in the PJs you thing like this
there's nothing like Oh muffin I heard
Katie the brook yours that was it I know
Katie thing Willowbrook yeah but I
always stand over there well no like I I
mean you know how like how like like
when you were younger how you have more
fun like that's not me you know like
that's like when I was younger and more
pain and she like that you know and I
was like to run it for my [ __ ]
problems you know what I mean and just
like I was just always confused you know
like because I don't get why or I don't
know how or I don't know what for wait
they choose the street should be better
than went home treat me you know but
home careful for me and love me more
than its trees do you know but I don't
know you know I mean like I don't
[ __ ] know my [ __ ] like when I was a
kid like when I was I mean I still am a
kid don't get it [ __ ] up but I mean
like when I was younger but I didn't
have like I don't do nothing you seen me
like like like what is there to do that
I don't go to prom I go to none of that
like you seem like I didn't do it you
know what I mean like Oh
and if you like sometimes I just been
crying and she liked that you feed me
like at the Bluebird just be like I hate
the fact that I got to the point where
all I can say is I don't know you know
and I noticed that I said that a lot you
know like I don't know right because
sometimes I really don't like cuz I know
that I [ __ ] up like you see me I
couldn't I couldn't be doing something
better you know like
and I don't I don't want to know like
why like I said I want to know like why
like at all these kids like why me you
know like what did I really do sometimes
like it's like
I was like I wanna feel like I'm gonna
uh I want to feel like when like I don't
know what it's like to be a kid you know
like I never had fun you feel be like
like life is not fair
like I everybody to deserve a chance
everybody gets a chance but it's just
like when I see I feel like I did it you
know cuz it's like damn I like okay me
growing up having to be a corner [ __ ]
almost [ __ ] like I don't remember
nothin like
you